yes
all right y'all
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
happy holidays
and welcome to
your favorite
[Music]
[Music]
coming in strong
yes daddy got cozy
so we're going to talk all about the
covet
and my covenant experience
and then i'm doing an intense review of
the matrix
and spider-man
so uh you know look out for that
spoiler alert
you know right off the bat spoiler alert
but i'm gonna try to make it through
with my voice but i really appreciate
y'all being here
[Music]
okay
man all right y'all
welcome to riffing with griffin um
the covet edition yes
i do
have
covet let me pop the chat out so i can
see it right here
um
[Music]
yeah there we go let me see if this
works perfect
so i can see the chat right in front of
me um yeah man so i got covet uh so but
anyways first of all merry christmas
happy holidays to all the people and i
hope you had a really great christmas
even with covet i had a really fantastic
christmas because of um
rachel
rachel made christmas like really
special
for me
um you know
when you get older you get to a certain
age where like holidays birthdays and
other stuff mean anything to you i think
i've talked about this already but like
you know rachel's out here decorating
she had like a beautiful tree set up we
moved it over to another corner and then
like you know she had all these gifts
under the tree for me like she had like
so many gifts and then we had stockings
and so she had like a bunch of stuff in
the stockings for me too so it was just
like i was like oh man so it made me get
into it you know i was like oh wow
somebody cares about me you know
and then like she got all these uh
really nice things for me i got like a
beard comb i should have used it right
now because i made my beard puffy
some jeans i wanted it was like very all
very thoughtful gifts that i really
wanted you know and then i got her some
diamond earrings and some headphones
that she don't really want to headphones
because she don't really use headphones
but you know
uh it was nice we
had a good time but
i did get coveted you know so let's talk
about that and i see my cousin in the
chat
shout out to alyssa
all the way from the virginia dc area um
yeah so covet guys uh let's you know
let's get into it um
i don't know where
because like
i'm
listen i'm not a scientist i never claim
to be
but you know just from my little
information that i read about and hear
about you know covet you could get it
like you know you could be exposed to it
and it may not show itself
for like two to 14 days apparently or
something along those lines but it's not
like somebody breathes on you and then
you have covert immediately or you show
any signs of it so i'm not sure when
uh at the point of say
last monday what
because i believe i got it in arizona
with those animals in arizona okay you
know just they don't care about nothing
out there and but by the way
i up to this point i haven't gotten
covet at all and i've been out on the
road doing meet and greets
you know what i mean like i'm i'm doing
meet and greets with fans you know i'm
hugging fans and i've been doing that
now for like five months
and i just figured you know i'm fully
vaccinated um and i was just like all
right you know what i'm i i do like
immune boost ivs i'm trying to take
vitamins i'm trying to get my you know
be healthier healthy as possible in
terms of that so i just was one of these
things was i just don't think i'm gonna
get covet sure enough i got covered
but anyways so it could have been there
you know it could have been at any point
when i came back i mean i did a show at
the improv
the other night and the comedy store and
now i know i know i hear a bunch of
people you know hitting me up like oh
yeah i got covered too and i'm like damn
so at any point at any time you could
get coded you know what i mean you don't
know where you're getting it from or
who's exposed or who's not exposed but
you can get it
so and then i'm fully vaccinated so i'm
like well you know there's like
whatever the myths were that they told
us in the beginning because i was one of
those people that thought well once you
get vaccinated you don't got to worry
about covid all right well that wasn't
right so apparently you could get covid
even if you vaccinated or not okay
so and you don't know where or how long
it takes or when you know it's hard to
even determine when you got it or
anything like that
which
begs the question
and let me just speak i'm speaking for
me but i'm sure a lot of you have this
same question too all right
why they checking for vaccinations now
then
like if i have to go to work if i'm
going to a restaurant or a comedy club
why the hell they checking for
vaccinations if
anybody could get covert at any time
from anyone
then
what are we doing
like who who's that dog in pony show for
because here's what i'm saying now
either
fully shut down
either just
shut the whole thing down again like hey
we got to get a handle on this or leave
me the [ __ ] alone
because
what are you doing it for who's it for
like you know you checking at the door
let me see if you're vaccinated
i could still have covet
here's the
here's the crazy part about it too like
i said the incubation period of it is
like you like okay let's say you go into
a like i went to a party i went to this
party where
you had to get a cover test at the party
here's the thing though let's say i was
exposed to covet the day before
and then i take a covet test the day of
you can still i'm just saying you could
still have covet even if you even if you
test negative on a
one of
these fast covet tests
like i don't know what's accurate
anymore i don't know what's accurate i
don't know what to believe
so now i'm sitting here like oh you can
just get covered at any time vaccinated
or not
then what are we doing like at this
point it's gotta be hey
anybody's gonna get covey it ain't even
about
how or if
it's a matter of when
when are you gonna get covered we're all
gonna get coveted period that's just my
belief now so if that's the case leave
me the hell alone when i go someplace
because at this point now when you're
telling somebody to get vaccinated it
ain't for me to help you
i ain't getting vaccinated for you
you have to now get vaccinated for
yourself
or if you're young and healthy then live
a healthy lifestyle or whatever you're
going to do but you better make sure you
start taking care of you because at this
point you can get it from anywhere
anyone at any time and you just got to
make sure that you don't have any like
you know bad symptoms so
i started to feel it
i started to feel sick like oh man i'm
trying to think what day that was but
maybe like five days ago i came back
from arizona didn't feel nothing
i wasn't feeling anything you know
and then like i i had that show at the i
went to the comedy show the improv and i
was feeling a little something but not
but like now i look back on it now
thinking oh i think that's what that was
but i don't know you know what i'm
saying
and so
i i performed that night and then the
next day i was scheduled to get an
immune boost iv i like to get these
immune boosts for iv from nextel shout
out to next health i love those guys
and i get those all the time you know
and so
i'm going to get them i'm sitting in
there you know you got your mask all
that [ __ ] and then
you you they want you to take your blood
pressure before you do an immune boost
or any iv
so my blood pressure is a little high so
that's like the first time that's ever
happened so i was like huh so i had to
sit there for a little while calm down
and they took it again and everything
was fine even though it still was a
little high so that was the first sign
and then somebody says to me hey man are
you okay and i'm like yeah i feel okay
you know uh but then i thought well
maybe i'm not okay right so i do the
immune boost i get home we got this home
covet test i took the [ __ ] sure enough
cove it and i was like oh no
it was like i was like this is crazy
so then
then it's almost as if once my mind knew
it was covered but my body was like all
right let that [ __ ] in and then i
started to feel it man
so my first night
i had
really bad headaches i had headaches i
had like my sinuses were like but it
wasn't to the point where i couldn't
breathe
uh i didn't have a bad
excuse me look guys
as i'm about to say cough i start to
cough i didn't have a bad cough it was
like how it is right now you notice i'm
coughing maybe not as often but i guess
because i'm using my voice a lot i start
to cough um
not really having a runny nose or
anything like that but it was really
about the headaches and the chills
i was having some chills
so
um
then i
you know so that night was tough
but then the next day i immediately
started to feel better but then i was
starting to have like like my chest was
feeling a little
i was feeling something in my chest now
that scared me because when you look up
you google like you know covet symptoms
and one of the symptoms that that says
is like if you have blue lips or if you
have like if it's blue on your
fingernails or if there's really
tightness in your chest they said that's
an emergency
um that's an emergency situation so go
to the doctor
but then anxiety can cause that too so
it's kind of like twofold because i'm
reading like you know i'm getting
anxiety because i'm feeling something in
my chest so i'm like is it because of
covid or now like am i making myself
more anxious you know what i'm saying so
i was like oh no and i was a little
nervous about it so i wanted to pay
attention to that but then like i took a
couple of tylenol
and that subsided like right away and
then i haven't felt that since like you
know it
so that so that was done
um
so then every day since
every day i wake up i feel
i feel better but i've been taking
multivitamins vitamin c
and vitamin d
i took some magnesium i've been doing
that kind of stuff along with taking
tylenol
just you know
aches and pains and
and then like another symptom was i was
feeling weak you know what i mean like i
just felt overall weakness um
but like today i feel
a lot better but i could i still know
that i'm sick
i still know that i'm sick you know
so
it didn't hit me super hard to the point
where it was like i need to go to the
doctor or anything like that but like i
don't know like if i wasn't vaccinated
or if like
maybe to that immune boost i took it's
probably helping me too
but like
because that's like full of vitamins and
nutrients and all that kind of stuff to
help you fight stuff so like i feel like
man maybe if i hadn't taken that stuff
this could have hit me harder but you
know i just don't know you know what i
mean i'm vaccinated so it's like
whatever you know what i mean so it's
like i don't
you know you don't know until like you
know
i don't want to know actually i don't
want to sit here and be like well if i
wasn't vaccinated i probably could have
got through this i don't know at my age
so i'm like i just was playing i wanted
to be safe and sorry and i was supposed
to get my booster today that's another
thing that pisses me off i was scheduled
to get my booster today and now i
couldn't do it because of this
so it's just like
you know who knows but anyways
make your own choices out there but i
will say
i'm i'm i'm
i don't know what we're doing like i
honestly don't know what we're doing let
me just say again i don't understand now
why when you go places they're asking
for you to be vaccinated when anybody
can get the damn virus
like anybody can get it like this this
whatever variant that's out there that's
like you know just tearing through
people so quickly it's so easy to pass
that sucker don't care about your
vaccination status
so i
i don't know maybe i'm one of these
unlucky ones that's but actually i can't
even say that because
i know now 10 people in the past week i
know 10 people who are fully vaccinated
who got covet so if that's the case i'm
tired of you asking me about my
vaccination status
get out of my face
i'm tired of going to a restaurant
talking about oh you could only be in
here if you're vaccinated and we still
getting covey and we ain't even using
masks in the restaurant so it's like hey
shut up
at this point i feel like it should just
be like
you're gonna get covet
that's your business
you need to deal with it you need to
deal with it however you're gonna deal
with it if you decide that you don't
want to get vaccinated and you get super
sick that's on you but at this point
who are we trying to protect like who we
trying to protect at this point right
now knowing that you know
i don't know maybe that's the whole idea
is that
let's just
let's just be better to be safe than
sorry so we don't want to be responsible
for the people that don't want to get
vaccinated so you come to my restaurant
you have to be vaccinated you're
probably still going to get covert but
at least we don't have to worry about
you dying maybe that's the thought
process i don't know but at this point i
just go what are we doing it's kind of
frustrating you know what i mean holding
this up and then like they're traveling
and stuff and then like you know they
cancel their flights and stuff and i get
why they're cancelling flights because
the damn
the stewardesses and the the flight
attendants and all these people they're
sick
you know you got up somebody with covet
roaming up and down the aisles and so
they don't have enough staff to like
take care of the flight so they got to
cancel flights so i don't know i don't
know what's going to happen moving
forward but unless they come up with
some kind of thing that's like you know
tylenol covered in flu
unless they come up with that
man
it's gonna be a bunch of like oh yeah
you can't do this for ten days you can't
do that for ten days
or whatever you know until you test the
pot negative and at that point you you
know what's going on with your life not
everybody has to where not everybody has
the ability to like not go to work or
not do stuff you know
you got stuff playing like this feels
like weird to me it feels scary and it
feels weird like what kind of world are
we gonna be living in right now what
kind of world we going to be living in
where we're going to constantly be in
fear of
you know covet and then like this strain
they trying to make like the thing about
this strain apparently is not that it's
like super strong but it's just super uh
contagious
so like you know and it's so weird too
because like rachel don't got it
rachel don't got coveted
so we're like separate like i'm in the
other room and she's been upstairs and
so we try to stay away from each other
and
it's crazy though yesterday
yesterday rachel was all like you know
oh my god i think i have covered i need
you to go to the store and i was like
hold on a second
i actually just she took two coving
tests and no nothing she's negative
she's
upstairs talking about she thinks she
got coveted and she like i need you to
go to this you need to go to the store
and get some stuff for me and i'm like
hold on a second i actually have covet
so in her mind if she has covet
her covet cancels out my covet and now i
gotta take care of her
i'm telling you man
women be crazy
but then she like got over it she's like
whatever but i'm like
i know it's like so
this these
these common like this is
i feel like like i'm looking at the chat
and thanks for being here live
you know
you looking at the chat
i'm saying i'm looking at the chat you
know you you um
[Music]
you know if somebody
if somebody gets
if they had like an uh like the common
cold's called the common clothe right
like if i said to you like hey i think i
got the flu
like and all mine triggers oh you're
sick you got a cold
and then we kind of move on
but if i gave the flu like a name like
you know
you know booga booga or something like
that i'd be like yo man i got that booga
booga you're gonna be like oh you got
booga booga you got that booga boo get
away from me and then we started acting
crazy blue is all over the place i mean
that's what i'm saying when you put like
a name like omicron
and like these kind of names to
what feels like a cold
well but by the way i ain't no doctor
and i'm not trying to say that it's not
deadly because i still according to like
when you look up these numbers and stuff
you know people of preexisting
conditions people with obesity people
who are like not vaccinated who are like
older and
you all need to watch out okay you need
to watch out for getting covet because
it can mess you up
you know uh but i just think for
a seems to be a
larger portion of the population because
this is not
it's not that serious in terms of like
death
you know what i mean
or even hospitalization so i mean i
think that if the hospitals like they're
talking about it's a huge surge but like
people are at home and how many people
are not even going getting tested like
at some official place
like i think a lot of people are just
like oh i got covet and then they stay
home for 10 days or they stay home until
they test negative so like the testing
industry that's another scam i feel like
is going on too you can't even get a
test right now so they got they had to
you know that's what people are doing
you're just at home you you take a test
the test says negative and then you're a
positive then you're like [ __ ] i got
covered and you're telling all your
friends may i got covey man i'm gonna be
at home for five six seven days
and then you know you're not going to
the doctor you're not reporting it to
the cdc nothing you just i think that's
a lot of people i think this is
everybody that i know everybody that i
know unless they went to an official
place to get uh the the test but
everybody's like you know they put it on
instagram they're getting positive and
they put a little test on instagram like
damn look guys i'm tested positive and
then they're moving on with their life
so
i don't know
thank you for all
excuse me thank you for all the well
wishes a lot of people have sent me like
good messages on instagram and stuff
like that and i look like a crazy person
too look at me i haven't shaved my beard
is a mess
hair is a mess because i just been home
so
i hope you uh
you know
you guys um
just be safe out there and like i said
again thank you for the well wishes
and thank you for you know always being
there for
griffin with
griffin
all right guys um
you know what i got to do now is we got
to talk about
my new sponsor which is ritual
and you go to ritual.com slash griffin
richard was offering my listeners 10 10
off during your first three months go to
ritual.com griffin to start your ritual
today you know you need to you need to
know what you're putting in your bodies
and especially this time right now
having a good source of multivitamin is
super important
so you know you'll find there's no
sugars no gmos no major allergens
synthetic fillers and artificial
colorants in these vitamins
plus they have a fresh taste and delayed
release capsule design
making taking vitamins
easy
all right they got they got all the key
nutrients that your body needs i've
highly
listen i'm highly into
getting on a good vitamin regimen
especially at my age but you look you
read the numbers you hear about how
people are vitamin d deficient people
aren't getting enough b12 you would be
surprised i know you might think you're
healthy out there but you know uh take a
look at getting in into some
good vitamin thing and this day and then
we have like a thing where they'll send
it to you you know what i mean you can
sign up and and they'll send it to you
it's delivered to your door every month
with free shipping always you can start
you can start and snooze or cancel your
subscription anytime if you don't love
ritual within your first month they'll
refund your order
get key nutrients without the bs rituals
offering my listeners 10 off during the
first three months visit ritual.com
griffin to start your ritual today
that's ritual.com
griffin for 10 off during your first
three months ritual
all right let me secure the bag with
that
okay guys it's spoiler time so i'm
telling you right now
straight off the top spoiler spoiler i'm
gonna talk about the matrix first so
then the people because the matrix was
garbage do you hear what i'm saying guys
garbage so
let's go to that first
um
boom let's get that up
boom all right y'all
spoiler alert for all y'all
i saw the matrix that got us on hbo max
because i would be furious if i went to
the theaters and pay money to watch this
movie okay
like
whoo
my goodness all right so the matrix is
you know first of all oh by the way and
this i ain't even making a judgment on
this it's just something i didn't know
but did y'all know the creators of the
matrix the wachowski brothers are now
the wachowski sisters
did y'all know that i did i feel like
that should have been bigger news or
it slipped by me i didn't know
um but
yeah the matrix um
my god
so anyways they made this new matrix and
it's called the matrix resurrections
and that should be a key right there to
let you know that the [ __ ] is terrible
anytime they got to add
a like a title like description like
that anytime they got to add like
resurrection or revenge of or you know
any kind of stupidness any kind of dumb
name like that or in space or or
something like that that's usually a
sign this sucker is not good okay now
first let me just say this the reason
why i'm so down on this movie is because
the matrix the matrix the original
matrix man
in 1999 i believe it was
the matrix might have been one of the
most influential
movies
of the last 50 years
i mean i can't think of another movie
that was more influential and important
to the movie going experience than the
matrix
like you just talk about
all that the matrix added to
just society into the lexicon or
whatever that thing is to the underbelly
of like uh
you know like pop culture and all that
the matrix added to
[Music]
you know what i mean like
i was thinking about this and you can
fill it in and chat to you guys that are
watching live and people listening later
you can still do it to yourself and you
can put a comment later but
i'm i was thinking of like my top five
most influential movie going experiences
for me in my lifetime
um
and i was thinking about i was like what
is the most what is the top five movie
going experiences i've ever had
number five would be
when i saw a return of the jedi in the
theaters
in 70 whatever it was or 80 i forgot
when return of the jedi came out but i
was a young kid
and i don't even remember watching
empire strikes back or even star wars
because i was too young i was born in 72
yeah daddy's old
and so
about it by 70 i was like maybe five or
six so like you don't even remember but
i was old enough to like be like what's
going on with return like everybody was
talking about return of the jedi
everybody was like it's you know is it
is darth vader his father and all this
stuff and and i was like super excited
because everybody was excited like in
the movie line but the reason why it was
um a really influential movie experience
for me
was because
return of the jedi was the first time
thx sound was put into movie theaters
so that was the first time you were
sitting in the theater and you had this
movie going experience of the surround
sound
like this you know and you were like oh
my god the sound's over there it's over
there so that's what made that like
super influential
um
return of the jedi number four you know
and maybe my list changes but number
four i think was when i saw aladdin
and really i should even say like little
mermaid but little mermaid was so girly
that it was like but aladdin
and also me being like
like really being a fan of robin
williams and like
the change of like cartoons like aladdin
was the change where cartoons were like
oh this is actually
something different
and
the el capitan theater in hollywood they
would put on a show before the movie so
like people would come out singing and
dancing and stuff and doing disney stuff
and then the movie would play so i
remember watching aladdin in the
theaters like eight or eight or nine
times
aladdin is one of my favorite movies
ever that cartoon and it changed the
course of like cartoons after that it
was like you know that's when it went
into like you were like oh this is
actually a viable thing these are like
big time movies and you know after that
pixar launched and all those kind of
things happened those kind of like were
people were making cartoons not just for
kids but for adults too
so
that was like a really great movie going
experience
then number three i would say
was the matrix
like because the matrix was like oh [ __ ]
like this really
like you in that theater like
what
you know what i mean and just like the
special effects and like you you you
know they've already announced it's
going to be a trilogy and it's like
you're like oh man and then like you
know
keanu reeves is playing such a great job
being like neo because you're neo in the
movie you know because when you watch it
you relate to him because he's asking
questions with that hey what's that then
they would explain it you know and then
you were getting all the explanation and
just like it just was so the fighting
the just everything about the matrix i
was like oh man this is dope i love this
movie and it just went on to like you
know all the other ones were trash the
first matrix was the best but all the
other ones were trash
i don't know what number two would be
somebody said terminator i do feel like
the
i feel like
um
that terminator 2 terminator 2 was like
also a big time like movie experience
where you're there like oh [ __ ] this is
crazy
you know but the number one my i know
what my number one is my number one
movie going experience of all time
was jurassic park
okay
when i was sitting in that theater
and those dinosaurs came on the screen
the whole theater was like
what
the
[ __ ] oh i know what number two is by the
way i'm gonna go back to it number two
is actually related to the other movie
i'm going to talk about
the number two best movie experience was
spider-man
when the first spider-man came out with
tobey maguire because i used to collect
spider-man as a kid
so what like the technology was now at
the point where you could actually
visualize you could see the things that
you want to see and so it was amazing to
be like wow superhero movies are good
this is this is it right here you know
what i mean
you know
and i think like even if i tie if i make
a tie i would say spider-man and batman
begins
because batman begins to change the
superhero genre forever
so those are like tied but
jurassic park man when i'm watching
jurassic park i mean the whole theater
was like in just
in awe because that's the first time we
saw a computer generated
animal that looked like real life
and it was just amazing you know
so i saw that i might i think i saw
jurassic park like 10 times and steven
spielberg is just a master storyteller
in terms of like building suspense on
the screen and it just was like so
amazing so that was uh
jurassic park was like a truly amazing
movie
experience so
anyways
i don't know why i got off track on that
i have covis my mind just wandering but
let's talk about the matrix all right so
again spoiler alert but matrix all right
this new matrix was terrible you hear
what i'm saying look at me this was
terrible now i'm explaining why i was
terrible i'm not just gonna trash the
movie without giving my thing like i
said before the matrix was such a great
movie it was so great to like be a part
of that and just follow that story even
though the other movies weren't as good
so you know we had this really great
world that they created they didn't
necessarily do
a great job in the next two that came
out after that but you know it still was
like so great now cut to 20 years later
however how many years later it is now
they're making a new matrix right matrix
resurrection so apparently in this new
matrix neo who we never saw what
happened to neo in the in the end of
like the matrix the stupid one
he gets carried off
by the by the robots you know what i
mean and we don't know actually what
happens to theo to neo um and so now cut
to
this is obviously some new matrix
and this is like some weaker version of
neo of thomas anderson played by neo and
he's like a computer a software computer
developer and he developed a a game
called the matrix
and they're using footage from the real
movies
um as like as if this were a video game
in this universe which was stupid
because
he
he looks like him and you know it's like
like looks like real footage like how'd
they do that you know like in that
universe how did they create that okay
so
this is like that was dumb i didn't and
then it was like too aware of itself
so like so thomas anderson's in therapy
and he's in therapy um
he's in therapy played by uh what's his
name um
what's that dude's name guys help me out
who's the therapist name funny dude
um i lit but by the way i told you just
spoiler alert
so
spoiler alert okay uh
what's his name
um um
anyway
what um
what is it oh here we go here we go here
we go here we go i got neil patrick
harris there you go so neil patrick
harris is playing like his therapist
okay
so thomas anderson is clearly oh okay so
the movie opens up and it's like
that same scene from the original matrix
where trinity is like in this room and
then the agents come it's kind of
playing out the same way so you're like
what's going on but of course there's
new characters
you know what i mean and you know you're
just kind of like what's going on this
kind of like this overview look of like
this these other people are witnessing
this same thing so you know the matrix
still is is up and running and you're
trying to figure out like what the hell
is going on with this you know what i
mean and they're trying to explain like
you know it's just it just was to me it
was like too on the nose too aware of
itself of being like okay so it's like
now this is a way of control being like
making people think hey
you know oh this was just a video game
but could it be real and like he's like
in this delusional state of you know and
so his therapist is trying to convince
him
no there was no other alternate universe
you made this all up and so
as a viewer you know this
they're [ __ ] with him you know what i
mean so you don't know
and then it just goes just
i fell asleep two times trying to watch
this on
the hbo max like i fell asleep
like it was so boring like so boring
trying to figure out this story
you know what i mean like i just
oh my god
and then here's a okay
here's something that pisses me off
if you can't get the original actors to
play their characters
make a different story
okay just make a different story
i don't know why
lawrence fishburne wasn't in this movie
okay
i saw i saw a a post about it that
someone asked him specifically why
weren't you in the matrix and he said i
don't know
ask the director so i was like ooh that
made me feel like there was some kind of
thing going on
you know what i mean like i felt like
there was some kind of thing going on
between them and that's the reason why
he wasn't in the movie
but either way it was stupid now they
were showing old footage of lawrence
fishburne as
morpheus
from the video game which was footage
from the original movies so i'm sure he
got paid for that or who knows
but they had some other guy playing
morpheus and i was like nope sorry
don't do that
this would be like if they made
a you know like let's say
they they made star wars you know what i
mean like the new star wars comes out
and like jake gyllenhaal is playing han
solo
we would be like or even somebody less
known than that we'd be like where the
hell's harrison ford he's alive why
isn't he han solo like what are you
doing
it didn't make any sense to me like i
was like no thank you
morpheus is still alive and then of all
the characters that they gonna keep in
the movie they keep niobi
with the worst makeup old person makeup
ever
like
totally unbelievable jada pickett smith
is now the leader of like this new city
that's not zion anymore they got a new
name for it
i was like no thank you
and then you know they tried to bring
back other characters from the old movie
oh my god it was just so bad
you know the fighting
like
like the the final scene is this like
it's dark and and neo keeps doing the
bullet thing where he's like he
remembers his power
it and then it turns i don't you know
what i ain't going to even spoil it for
like people that actually want to watch
it i'm just telling you
i fell
the frick asleep on this movie
you know what i mean
like i fell asleep
and then i woke up the next morning like
let me finish this and i still was like
ugh so and i think that they're going to
continue
you know and of course now all of a
sudden
this is how they got to do it now all of
a sudden neo's weak and trinity's flying
around now and she's the one that's
going to be like the one that's gonna
save everybody or something i mean i
don't even know and by the way let's
just talk nerd [ __ ] right now let's
delve into the matrix universe of these
computers who are now
running the world right
computers
how the hell
they still allowing
people to escape from the pods
please explain this to me
they got neo and trinity in some secret
high security pods
because the new leader of the matrix
knows that they're the key to keeping
everybody in line
so they got them in this like supposed
to be secure location
and
all of a sudden
all of a sudden they can still get snuck
out they like what
i i
if they're robots you don't need like
the robots don't need to like go on
shifts
they don't need to like you could just
have a hundred sentinels around them at
all times to make sure yeah y'all just
watched them that's your job that's your
job is to watch these pods and don't let
nothing happen why the hell would they
leave these pods just like oh yeah boom
boom and then oh neo got neo escaped
again are you kidding me
are you kidding me like that was so
stupid
i just
it's so stupid like there's a point in
the movie where like they realize
trinity's gonna escape and then the guy
goes destroy her and then a hundred
thousand sentinels come fly those
sentinels should always be around those
pods
there's no freaking way they should be
able to escape so that was stupid it was
stupid
i don't get it it's like
do people make these movies and then
look and go yeah that makes sense
it feels like it's a lot of yes man for
once i wish like directors and writers
they would grab like a focus group of
nerdy matrix fans just nerdy matrix fans
and be like okay what do you think of
this and then we would go nah man that's
dumb why wouldn't the senators and then
he could be like you know what you're
right let's add that in or something
like talk to the people that you like
just because you create something don't
mean that like
everything you're saying about it is
right
oof
oof
y'all hear what i'm saying
oof
it was bad
i mean it was
bad anyways
if you're just coming in right now
i do have covet i'm feeling a lot better
today
i'm getting over it
wanted to do the podcast live because i
need to get the podcast excuse me
podcast out
um
i just spoiled i didn't really spoil it
but i talked about the matrix
the matrix skits you don't even get a
full woo boo and just get a
that's it i give it i give it no
woo-woos cause it was just bad
uh but if you got
a hbo max and you can watch it for free
just watch it you got to watch it just
you could be like why like what did they
do this for like it just to me it just
feels like they dropped the ball
you know like like it's like it's like a
great concept like some of the stuff in
the movie i really like like obviously
like some of the robots
are now free beings they're sentient so
they're like you know what i'm making my
own choice i don't want to be with these
robot people and then there's people you
know it's like still a system obviously
human beings are still being like used
as batteries and all this kind of stuff
and it's just the whole thing was just a
nightmare man
i i just
there's so many holes in it but it was
it just was a way it was a waste of time
so thumbs down on on the matrix and no
woo-woos for the matrix
all right so major spoiler alert again
all right so
i want to talk about
the best movie i've seen in a long
ass
time
spider-man no way home
spider-man
no way home
was
dope
dope dope dope this was such a fun movie
okay and at this point right now
everybody already knows that it's a
multiverse movie and they had everybody
in the from the multi from the other
movies you know it would and even stay
for the if you make sure you stay for
the trade for the end credits and the
actual n nnn credits because they got
some uh some little teaser things there
too which i thought was kind of cool but
this was a really
this was a really great movie and i'm
gonna tell you how great it was it was
so good i think i cried four times in
this movie
that kid tom holland is a really
fantastic actor
and the movie just like i say it was so
fun
so as you know the previous movie
spider-man
i don't know what the hell dumb name of
that one was but at the end of that
movie everybody knows that peter parker
is now spider-man
so now he's the most famous person in
the world you know what i mean and he's
like you know trying to live his life
but it's not going well
he goes to dr strange
who's played by what's his face uh
benedict cumberbatch who does a great
job like
he is the closest thing to like
you know that tony stark energy
uh
you know of robert downey jr's
sort of commanding presence
benedict cumberbatch is the only person
that can hold that and he's and he can't
even hold it the way but he's the one
you could tell i can tell he's gonna be
the one that's gonna have that thing
so
he goes to him like yo man can you cast
a spell
so everybody can forgets that i'm peter
parker that peter parker spider-man
so he starts to cast the spell and then
like peter parker's like but wait a
minute i want my girlfriend to know and
so anyway the spell goes haywire okay
and it opens up a multiverse all right
and in this multiverse all the villains
not all the villains but the major
villains from the other spider-man
universe the tobey maguire spider-man
and the andrew garfield spider-man
universe they're all now in this movie
jamie foxx uh you know the the you know
the hobgoblin and you know uh dr octopus
uh you know like these people are now
from those other movies
these are the villains now that are in
these movies
and
you know it was great you know what i
mean like it was like because if you saw
the multiverse cartoon with the black
kid as the spider-man
that movie was so good
these people were like let's do the same
thing let's just have a multiverse and
so they made this multiverse and they
sort of hinted at the multiverse in
their avengers end game anyway you know
about like you know when the lady's
talking about like if you t you know you
have to return the stones to the
original point because all these other
universes and then you know within the
time cops within the loki universe so if
you're in the loki universe you know
that like there are alternate timelines
so this is something that's already
prevalent in the
mcu universe so they brought it in on
this spider-man so we're all on board
with this and they did a really great
job
like there's so many like cheering
moments you know what i mean like when
when uh
andrew garfield first shows up
i mean the whole theater cheered and
then everybody was like so excited
because it was like well if he's there
toby maguire's got to be there right and
of course toby maguire shows up and the
whole place goes ballistic it was like
you really got a good feeling from the
movie you really got like it was a great
movie going experience the action was
great the drama was great like you know
they had all these parallels like you
know uncle ben dies with great power
comes great responsibility all that kind
of stuff yada yada
that was all part of the movie too so
this particular spider-man he had his
own story which i love that they did you
know because everybody lost someone and
gained someone
it would have been nice to see kirsten
dunst you know as his mj i would have
liked to have seen that you know but you
couldn't get everybody you know and they
didn't do something stupid like the
matrix and like just get some random
actress they just ignored it you know
what i mean she's just gone you know
what i'm saying i didn't spoil it you
look on the internet i told you hey i
told you spoiler alert louis so [ __ ] off
this is a spoiler alert episode it's in
the damn preview okay and then the damn
thing so if you don't want to see it
then just get out i don't care
um
yeah so when all these people show up it
was like super exciting
the final fight was like the final fight
stuff was like really good
it was just like it was so dope
you know and okay now here's a big
spoiler right here okay and this ain't
even really a spoiler all right this
isn't necessarily a spoiler but this is
just a theory i have all right
and it sucks too by the way
this sucks what i'm about to say but
this is the truth of the matter
they literally found a way
to remove spider-man from the mcu
that's what they did in this movie by
the way
so i don't know what's going on behind
the scenes
but spider-man's not gonna be in any
more avengers movies i don't think
i think that
spider-man is now gonna be strictly a
sony i think sony won the battle or
whatever happened
they made it so
if they don't want to
spider-man is no longer going to be in
the avengers
you know that's how they did it so they
took back spider-man and
this is what it is
you know now i won't tell you how they
did that but they did it
oh and they would you know what like see
if you're if you're a marvel nerd and
you've been watching the marvel shows on
netflix and you've been watching the the
disney plus shows
any little any little
thing to that was really great
like yes
um
what you call it
what you call it uh
um homeboy from daredevil was in the
movie like the daredevil from the
netflix show was in the movie and i
loved that that little moment i was like
oh is he gonna be in it now like like
all those little teasers was great for
the movie
so
so somebody said in the chat that tom
holland signed a new deal
well even if he signed a new deal it
doesn't mean that he's gonna be in the
avengers anymore that's all i'm saying
all i'm saying is
they set the table for
um spider-man is no longer an avenger
because
you know you know what i mean you'll see
they they set the table for that which i
thought was great in terms of because
they did it great like if we never see
spider-man with you know the hulk and
all those people ever again
i'm okay with it because i like how they
did it
but
all this stuff that they got going on is
a really good man like i want you to do
like if you let me give you some marvel
homework right now i'm gonna give you
some marvel homework right now one you
gotta watch loki if you ever watch loki
so watch loki
i think you should go back and watch
daredevil because they got they just put
it back on netflix right now and i know
why they did it they did it because he
was in that movie all right but
like it or hate it i think you should
watch black widow you gotta watch black
widow and then watch hawkeye on disney
plus hawkeye is
dope
that is a dope show okay
loki is dope captain america one is dope
uh you know the um winter soldier and
and the falcon that's dope and it's all
connected man it's all connected i love
what they're doing the whole [ __ ] is
connected and so that chick that plays
black widow's sister
that chick is a great actress
and she really makes it and so she's you
know so you got to watch that so this
whole mcu stuff that they got going on
is really great i really love it but
like i said spoiler alert i do feel like
they found a very clever way
to let themselves have the ability to
remove spider-man from the mcu
okay from the
you know the mcu as we know it of like
you know thor captain america iron man
that universe of movies i if they wanted
to it's done and now they got this new
stuff with the terrible eternals and
then shang shi which was good that one
was good so you know was and then you
got thor coming out and then you got um
uh
you know all those movies that are still
going to be connected
we may never see spider-man with them
again
all right
that's all i'm saying so check that out
florence pew that's her name exactly
yeah that chick is bad ass and she's
doing such a great job um but anyways i
didn't want to spoil spider-man too much
but just it was a really great movie
going experience it was like sad when it
needed to be sad it was moving it was
like this the pacing of the story was
good the action was like so intense the
comedy it was so funny too it was funny
but it was like really touching oh man
let me tell you oh my god i want to okay
spoiler
i just want to tell you like one of the
moments like because these all these
three guys like andrew garfield is a
really great actor too man he had a
moment in the movie that it was so
moving you know what i'm saying like it
was such a moving moment in the movie
and i won't even spoil it but he does
something in this like i don't even
remember his terrible spider-man movie
but
this was like omar excuse me homage to
that movie
that he didn't he wasn't able to
accomplish something in that movie that
he accomplishes in this movie and he let
you feel it with his acting and it was
so good you know what i mean it was so
good
i know i told you it was a spoiler it's
in the damn title of the thing spoiler
alert for all you people watching live
so it is what it is man i told you last
week if you watch my podcast on a
regular and i told you last week i said
you bet you have one week to watch it
because i will be spoiling the movie
next week i told y'all [ __ ]
okay so i don't know why you getting on
me right now so it is what it is
um
it is what it is you don't got to be
here right now
[Laughter]
uh
but um
it was really good um
you know you got to see all three
spider-man's on screen together that was
really cool
you know what i mean like it was just
really cool i'm glad they all decided to
do it too because like imagine if like
one of them was like yeah i don't wanna
do this i'm moving on from this that
would have been that would have sucked
they would have had to have changed it
but they easily could have just they
easily could have just been like like in
that other movie they could have just
like
made anyone be spider-man and we would
have believed it because it's a
multiverse so we would have been on
board with it you know what i mean but
the fact that they got tommy mcguire and
andrew garfield or whatever his name is
garfunkel or garf whatever
you know with tom holland
and then you know they were working
together and it was just dope you know
what i mean the spidey sense all that
everything about it was just really
great and what's her name uh uh you know
the what's the chick's name the main
chick um
you know
zendaya she was good and that kid the
asian kid was good too and i think that
they like teased something about him too
you know he because now he got magic you
know he was doing the portals spoiler
alert sorry
[Laughter]
so it is what it is um i get this movie
gets all the woo-woos as many woo-woos
as i could do
with my kovic off
all they get
then i got the kovic off
but
absolutely fantastic movie going
experience i do highly recommend you all
go see it it's already it's already got
over a billion dollars in the in the box
office because it literally was that
good of a movie so you know what i mean
anyways y'all
hopefully in like three or four more
days i'll be 100
but right now you know even talking like
this i'm feeling a little weak
uh
you know
voice
but it is what it is but i want to thank
you guys for watching riffing with
griffin thanks for being here thanks for
all the likes thanks for all the uh
super chats
um thanks for just being very supportive
make sure you check me out i'm gonna be
on air griffin gaming live
eric griffin gaming live will be on
there in like 20 minutes because i got
to prepare the audio for my audio
version of the podcast so make sure you
check that out
thanks for all the well wishes i'm
trying to get better at you know get
better
and oh and don't worry for all you guys
looking out for jenna jen
we are still doing gender gen but i got
kovid and then something also happened
with matthew so we got our schedules got
messed up but we already recorded the
episode and in 2022 we're coming in
strong on uh uh
you know 2022
so don't worry about that you know so
look out for gender gen 2. i'm also on
king of the sting
probably got to zoom in because i can't
go into the studio because i'm still
sick but you guys have been fantastic i
really appreciate you guys being here on
whiffler equipment and i will see you
next week
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]